thank you all for coming we're gonna get
started please
[Music]
all right i'm uh representative steven
smith vice chair of the committee and
deputy speaker of the house and i have
an opening i'm supposed to do so let's
get through it
thank you for attending this community
input session regarding redistricting
please be advised that the session will
be video and audio recorded to be
subsequently placed online and made
publicly available
this is not a typical meeting of the
house or senate committees and will not
be attended by all committee members
those meetings appearing in the colosse
county courthouse with the permission of
the court system and the county
commissioners and thank you for that and
we are grateful guests
please understand that while we are in
this facility neither the courts of new
hampshire nor the county commissioners
coast county have anything to do with
this public input session or the
redistricting process as it is underway
in the general court
staff of the general court has worked to
secure places to hold these sessions and
i'm grateful to staff and the
organizations that control the use of
this facility for allowing us to use
them
we have members of both the house and
senate here with us tonight
from the house we have introduce
yourself please
karen mcguire representing allenstown
epsom in pittsfield in merrimack county
i'm also the chair of the housing dna
committee
marjorie smith
representing durham and mandarin in
stratford county and i serve on the
judiciary committee in addition to this
committee
connie lane i'm from concord ward 2 and
i serve on the election law committee as
well as this committee
one which is local westlawn chesterfield
and hinsdale so the lower left-hand
corner
and i serve up the health human services
and elderly affairs committee as well as
this
committee uh matt wilhelm i represent
manchester awards one two and three uh
serve on state federal relations
veterans affairs committee
macdonald i come from martinez
the finance school
thank you university and college from
the senate senator greg
thank you um
just a couple of matters for the senate
uh i am the chair of the slot committee
for redistricting in the senate i'm also
the chair of the elected law committee
of the senate um senate does not allow
uh cheering clapping booing
of any kind please be respectful of the
people who are
testifying
uh you'll have your opportunity to
express your feelings
you don't need to do it with clapping or
brewing or anything
i do want to recognize our
senator from kawasa county uh
aaron hennessey is in the audience now
i'm jim gray and i will let senator
perkins spoke and
introduce us
sure my name is uh senator rebecca coca
i represent district 21 which is
portsmouth surrounding market and the
surrounding towns and i'm on
election law and energy and natural
resources in addition to this committee
all right i'm supposed to ask you if
you'd like to open them
already you've taken care of that that's
awesome you actually have two hearings
going a house committee hearing in the
senate committee hearing and i've
already opened the senate one
knocked on the table quietly
love efficiency
uh this meeting will be placed online
and it's being watched right now is that
right graham
i think so anyway uh it'll be uploaded
at the very least
we're gonna have an overview of the
process
information on the redistricting process
for the house of representatives can be
found on the general court website once
you're there select house of
representatives then select committees
it's right up by the top and under that
you'll find standing committees
one of the standing committees is a
special committee on redistricting
go ahead and click on that and on that
page you will find a link that enables
you to email all committee members so
even after this it's still pretty easy
to contact us with your
thoughts and input on this process
you'll also find a link there for the
committee website that page has
additional information on it for the
special committee on redistricting you
will find among other things a link for
meeting minutes and recordings that is
where the video that is being taken here
tonight will be found
redistricting is a process that occurs
throughout the country every 10 years
after the federal census is completed
that population data is used to create
districts for representation at all
levels of government
here in new hampshire our constitution
says the responsibility for the creation
of those districts is that of the
legislature
the districts to be redrawn in new
hampshire will be the congressional
executive council state senate and state
representative there's also
redistricting for county commissioner
districts and delegates to the state
party convention
there are handouts here tonight with
some information for you i gave them to
represent the birds or it should be on a
bench there there
perfect
um that's more detail on coast county
from a house representative's side it
would be helpful for you to comment on
things you might think are important for
redistricting in coast county but you
can of course make comments in other
districts as well
we'll be doing this event in every
county
not on the sheep but something i really
want to say is the reason we're going
out is the thing that's hardest for us
to get is the local knowledge
these two towns are in the district they
got nothing in common or these two towns
have a ton in common and they're not in
the district um i'm from sullivan county
you can't drive through my district on
pavement without leaving the county to
do it so it's
nuggets like that that are really useful
to us because beyond that it's just a
lot of math there are sign up sheets for
people who like to talk we have a
microphone
up here you just speak engine
and since we're recording it's
particularly important for us all to be
able to hear
and i hope i'm doing it okay my wife
says i never have a problem with volume
all right we have people signed up and
we're going to call them uh when you're
called we're going to ask you to come up
to the
microphone a huge member of the public
will be provided with x number of
minutes to speak on the issue because
you know i'm not going to fill in the
number say what you want to say
already
first up
i have
ellen farnham
tim timmer
yes and i would like to say because i am
from carroll county if you would like me
to go after the people from coast county
i'm happy to wait
doesn't matter there's not a lot of
people it's fine all right thank you
and we're going to go through everybody
thank you
this looks like a lot but it's really a
giant font
um
dear members of the special committee on
redistricting and the senate and house
members i want to begin by thanking all
of you for the time and hard work you've
invested in this redistricting process
this is a huge responsibility and your
work will impact all of us in the years
ahead
this past year people in 74 towns and
municipalities around the state voted to
support the new hampshire resolution for
nonpartisan fair redistricting
clearly the public desires a fair open
and impartial redistricting process
your special committee has taken a good
first step by scheduling listening
sessions like this one
in all around in all of the counties
however the committee must follow up
these listening steps
these listening sessions with four
additional steps or actions
first the special redistricting
committee should immediately disclose
the criteria that is using to create new
voting districts
second once the maps are drawn by the
special committee they need to be made
available to public
each citizen deserves an opportunity to
see the maps study the maps and then
comment on the maps
therefore a second hearing in each
county is imperative
further the second hearing needs to
provide an option for citizens to
participate remotely i have spoken with
many people who cannot attend in-person
meetings due to coded concerns or other
health issues
many of them care deeply about
redistricting they deserve a chance to
both hear information and give testimony
directly to this committee remote access
would provide them with this opportunity
finally i want to urge you to
incorporate the popular population data
with communities of interest data
this spring non-partisan groups such as
the league of women voters and open
democracy gathered people from around
the state to participate in the mapathon
citizen mapping project
i was one of the citizens who
participated in this project by filling
out information on the town i come from
tamworth
the data was then meticulously compiled
and maps drawn using both population
numbers and community of interest data i
have looked at these maps and believe
they present fair non-partisan and
balanced solutions to redistricting
please consider these maps when you're
making their decisions and i want to
thank you again for giving me this time
to speak
thank you
is representative hatch in the house
come on down
i'll just be very pleased thank you
welcome to our beautiful county and
welcome to the north country just a few
things i'd like to
add and maybe these things are already
in consideration
i have no idea what any of you think of
co-ops
but from
for the years that i've been in the
legislature i've heard a variety of
statements from people that live in the
southern part of the state that really
don't depict what coz county
is that's not in themselves but i'm just
not sure everybody understands that
some of the things that i've heard that
everything in coast county is the same
all the communities are very similar um
nothing could be further from the truth
like many other places
and there's many other things um
we now
have changed from an area that is very
dependent upon the forest industry paper
making industry
which has since left us um just to put
that in perspective
when i bought my business in berlin 45
years ago
doing my due diligence one of the things
that i noted was the number of people
that work in the
paper making industry
whether it be aligned services or
support services like loggers and
otherwise or the paper makers and the
machinists that work in the middle
very good paying job
jobs et cetera and that was one of the
things that attracted me to the store to
buy out building reno building supplies
because the income base was stable and
it was good
there were 35 000 people working in the
paper industry in coast county
today
we're lucky if we have 200.
that transformation took place in a very
short period of time so so we're now in
a dynamic stage in this county and um
uh we're adjusting right now uh prime
young industry is a tourism industry
and we're very
thankful for it and we're very
protective of that and we're very
concerned that we
maintain things in place to attract and
be able to provide the services that
tourists come to and are attracted to
and that goes to my point for an example
i live in borough
many of you have stated to me that i'm
from berlin
nothing wrong with that but nothing to
beat further from the truth
gorham and shelburne the two communities
i represent are very similar in many
ways
we share a school district
and we share many other industries many
of us share churches and other social
functions so we're almost a community of
one though two separate individual
communities and there's a plethora of
other things that i can add to along
with that but my point is this
that though it's a numbers
focused item when you redistrict because
they have to work and you have to align
and many other things happen
i would just encourage you to please
consider
those aspects when you redistrict
currently my district has two
communities very closely aligned they
share services and they have many other
commonalities so in my mind it just
takes sense not just where i live but
many other places to consider those
factors because they should be
part of the makeup
and thank you
thank you
next up i have
rob christie of lancaster
[Music]
how about uh i hope i get this right
kathleen contra
i'm just an observer
okay
is there anybody else
come on down
i wasn't going to speak until i heard
representative hatch speak and i
realized
my name is edith tucker i represent
class 5.
and
4s5 hangs together
because we are a long time
tourist area
in my district
our two
uh grand hotels
the omni mount washington
in broad woods which is part of carl
which is one of the four towns i
represent
it's made up also of twin mountains
so twin mountain and red woods go
together as carol
the army crown washington
is an enormous
enterprise
and
the mountain view brand is also grand
hotel not as enormous
as the army about washington
but
they have the pluses of the tourist
industry
and they also have the costs
and worries about the tourist industry
when we're talking about multiple people
on weekends such as the one coming up
i also represent jefferson
and
randall where i live
a town of 300. but randolph because of
its hiking past
has been a tourist area
on what we now call non-motorized
it used to be foregone's inclusion
that recreation wasn't motorized
particularly but now it divides itself
into motorized and non-motorized
so
it's true that my district
has
two school districts
uh
not one
which would be probably nice
but the commonality of being long time
tourism
on having
built an economy on that
plus forestry
it wasn't the mills that were in
district five
it was the logging itself
the loggers the people who processed the
people who hauled
so
it's shifting too as
tourism is growing
and all of cos although we're by no
means the same
as has been said before
there is commonalities of dealing with
the planning population
dealing with
finding ways to keep our young people
here
to make sure that we have
dollars for education
and that we are preparing our young
people
to
make their way in a world that's really
quite different
than 10 or
30 40 years ago
and we needed an equity here
in co-ops so that we're able to give our
young people
the same benefits of education as others
so that aspiration that parents
grandparents and your great-grandparents
have is a commonality that all of co-ops
have
and it's very apparent that that's the
case the aging population of which i'm
apart
and i'm quite familiar with it
and there is tremendous worry about the
future here
and that is a commonality
so as you redistrict
be thinking about
sort of
aspirational
collective
views
and the kind of problems that were
resting
they're not that different
west stewart sound
from randolph
from berlin there is a commonality to be
in this county
and it's worrisome
to go from 10 representatives out of 400
down to nine
so your
work here
is tough in this county
and i'm aware of that
but think about
what it will be
to really represent
constituents if there are only nine
representatives
pretty tough
so
i also want to say
thank you for having me
here in this courthouse
very often
we have meetings and co-ops and
buildings that really aren't ada
accessible
this one is
it has all the improvements of
a modern building of sound and lights
elevators
and things that make it so people can
come here and i believe it was
executive counselor kenny who had the
idea
of having at the courthouse i think is
an excellent one thank you
thank you representative
anyone else
okay
what i'm not gonna do is wrap this after
only 26 minutes in case somebody
traveled a great distance and is running
late
so
um let's recess until
6 40 and see if anybody shows up
[Music]
welcome tell everybody who you are what
do you like to say thank you uh my name
is erin hennessey i am state senator for
district one which covers the northern
part of grafton county and all of
wonderful coast county
i am glad that you all are here this
evening to listen to our concerns
uh i am going to speak for the two of my
constituents who spoke this evening
thank you
um i apologize that nothing
more people didn't come out for this in
the
um months leading up to this we received
a lot of emails hoping that it's a free
and fair process and i want to thank you
for making this a
process where everyone can come in and
participate i just wish that others had
come in to participate this evening so i
want to just reiterate
um basically one comment about what my
um the reps in west county had mentioned
earlier and that is um coast county is
different from the rest of the state
because it's much more rural we're much
more
separated
from the southern part of the state
which continues to grow when i first got
into the house
like seven years ago somebody tapped me
on the shoulder and said oh this bill
that we're talking about cobra that's in
your area no cowork is not next to
littleton so people don't understand the
differences in the communities they
don't understand the difference in the
geographic area what the economic needs
are what the school needs are and we
much better if coast county continued to
have the representation of
representation that it currently has in
the house
i realized that probably the senate
district is not going to change much it
will still have
one senator so if you want to add two
um so thank you for taking the time this
evening i appreciate all of you coming
up especially you
senator nice to see you um so that's
what i have for you this evening
and if anybody would like to stay this
evening or enjoy
dinner in lancaster it's beautiful
there's many options lancaster motel
right down the street is newly renovated
it's beautiful
[Music]
all right anybody else
all right we will also close the house
hearing thank